hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast unraveling biology and
identifying targets with functional
genomic approaches supported by Lindy
array CRISPR library screens presented
by dr. David Piper director of R&D cell
biology
Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm julissa
Morozov lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
Thermo Fisher Scientific and Corporation
is the world leader in serving science
with revenues of 18 billion dollars and
more than 55,000 employees globally
their mission is to enable their
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer they help their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity
through their premier brands thermo
scientific applied Biosystems envision
Fisher Scientific and unity lab services
they offer an unmatched combination of
innovative technologies purchasing
convenience and comprehensive support
for more information please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation for
questions not answered today we will
follow up with participants via email
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the icon located on the lower right
of the screen
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem now I'd like to introduce dr.
David Piper
sir Piper has led teams that Thermo
Fisher Scientific for over ten years in
the development products and services
for cellular engineering biochemical
assays is cell based assays for the
screening of multiple target classes ion
channels GPCRs kinases nuclear receptors
pathway profiling and next-generation
solutions for drug discovery using IPS
sea based approaches these efforts are
directed at generating more passive
physiologically relevant cell models
through the use of reprogramming stem
cell culture characterization and
differentiation genomic engineering and
assay development currently as an R&D
director for the cell biology and
synthetic biology businesses he leads
teams that provide molecular biology and
cellular biology services including cDNA
library synthesis high-throughput
cloning CRISPR and Talon design and
generation Lenti virus generation Batman
virus generation cell engineering
multiple delivery and integration
platforms assay development multiple
detection formats linty array CRISPR
libraries and functional genomics
screening using either si RNA or CRISPR
based approaches please join me in
welcoming dr. David Piper I will now
turn the presentation over to him Julie
oh thank you for that introduction and
to all of our participants good morning
good afternoon and good evening and
thank you for joining us today
go ahead and advance to the next slide
here as mentioned I'd like to share with
you today some of our thoughts around
how to use the CRISPR crap CRISPR cash 9
platform for target identification and
just to kind of ground everyone there a
reminder that that process is really
about identifying the direct molecular
target typically a protein but in some
cases nucleic acids of a small molecule
disease or specific phenotype and you
know I bring that up because we often
think about it in terms of disease so
when we look at the lower panel there we
think
and about target identification as it
relates to human disease but oftentimes
in our screening paradigms today we do
phenotypic based assays that are
hopefully modeling that disease in an in
vitro cellular state and when we find
compounds or or other hits in those
assays it often requires unraveling what
the target of that compound was so
target ID can be used in both those
sorts of situations and what these
CRISPR libraries may allow us to do is
to really systematically knock out
individual genes within a cell or
pathway and thereby identify those key
genes that contribute to that phenotype
or that disease and help us translate a
picture of human disease or phenotypic
assays to tangible targets that can be
followed up upon in drug discovery or
basic research now I suspect everyone on
this call is well aware of what the
CRISPR caste 9 technology is but again
as just a quick anchor point this is a
an innate bacterial immunity system
discovered by Jennifer Dodd news lab and
elucidated further by Emanuel sharpen ta
Fang Zhang George Church and others and
ported into mammalian systems whereby
the Cassadine nucleus depicted here is
the green sort of blob Euler structure
and the guide RNA shown in the dotted
circles act as a concerted complex the
ribonucleoprotein complex to be directed
in a specific way to double-stranded DNA
where it where the nucleus then can make
a double-stranded break and that
double-stranded break can be repaired by
non-homologous end joining which often
results in the formation of an in dell
and if that in doubt creates a
frameshift we can often thereby generate
knockouts of genes which is what we'll
be talking about today
of course donor DNA can also be included
there to model
the DNA in other fashions but today
we'll restrict the discussion to the
idea of making a knock out at the
specific site that the cast 9 R NP
complex has been directed at now of
course knockdown studies have been used
for decades now following on the use of
si RNA as well as SH RNA and both of
these approaches still carry a high
degree of validity and actually in
combination with these approaches create
a great orthogonal or counter screen the
main difference of course is with Si RNA
or shRNA you are knocking down the
message not the gene in some cases you
can get incomplete delivery or
incomplete knockdown of that message and
for those reasons in some cases that
data has been challenging to interpret
one of the promises of using cast 9
CRISPR systems here is that we expect to
see complete and permanent knockout of a
gene and expect that to give us a more
penetrate and more specific phenotype in
the cells that have been addressed so
what have we built to support this we
have two different systems and again I'm
sure many of you are aware with the
pooled lentiviral approaches that people
have taken and published in the
literature now over the past couple of
years we do have pooled libraries
available where we have generated
lentiviral guide RNAs targeting
approximately 10 guides per gene in the
pooled approach and these come delivered
as ready to use high titer lentivirus
with a very extensive QC around the
guide RNA representation what I'm going
to focus on today however is on the left
side which is our Lenti array CRISPR
libraries wherein we have generated
libraries with guide RNAs that target a
specific gene in each well with four
guide rnas per gene target so we've
generated 96 well plates
with about 80 of those wells filled and
each well again targets one specific
gene with up to four guides per gene and
we've organized the entire human genome
into subsets so we have about 17 sub
libraries that are based on gene
families and/or functional biology and
then for the things that don't tuck into
that very neatly we have two broad sets
one that we refer to as the druggable
genome so genes that the field believes
are druggable based on a number of
aspects about where those genes are
expressed typically and then the rest of
the whole genome which we'd simply refer
to as the whole genome so how are these
libraries constructed on the Left I have
a illustration of the Pawlenty caste 9p2
a Blastoise Eden vector that we use to
generate lentivirus expressing the caste
9 nucleus now here we have an ef-1 alpha
promoter driving the caste 9 open
reading frame and we have that connected
via a p2 a element to Blastoise Eden
resistance so when you use this Lenti
particle it will transiently Express
caste 9 or if you apply Blastoise Eden
antibiotics to the cells in an
appropriate way you'll be able to select
a pool of cells that are now stable
expressing caste 9 due to integration of
the lentiviral vector on the right we
have the Illustrated vector for the
guide RNAs
here we have a u6 promoter driving the
unique guide RNA then following that we
have a separate promoter the F alpha
promoter here driving pure myosin
resistance so again each particle
expresses a single guided RNA from a u6
promoter and the pyramus and resistance
is driven by a separate EF 1 alpha
promoter and of course all these
constructs or sequence verified
so the pure myosin here again allows you
to use these vectors in either a
transient application or in cell types
where transduction may be suboptimal say
less than 80 or 70% you can add pure
myosin to increase and enrich the
population for the cells that have
received the guides now in addition to
the libraries we also have a few control
particles that are important and helpful
in assay development so remember and I
will state this more than once a key to
a good screen is strong assay
development so you really want to make
sure they understand how your cells are
behaving how they're responding to the
virus how they're responding to specific
control positive and negative guide RNAs
so our controls are set up similar to
the guide structure with a u6 promoter
driving the guide followed by an ef-1
alpha promoter driving a GFP cassette
with a p2 a element connected to pyramus
in' now these can also be made available
without the GFP however with the GFP it
does allow you to use these vectors to
infect your cells or transduce your
cells with the viral particles and
understand the transduction efficiency
and to help you dial in the mo I of the
viral transduction based on purely the
expression of the GFP so this can be a
very helpful point at the beginning and
these are made with guides targeting the
hprt gene which in many cases we expect
to be an inert gene with respect to
biological certain biological pathways
and then we also have although we do
expect it to cut that gene and it does
allow you for a positive marker for
cleavage and we also have negatives
using a scrambled non targeting guide
which we expect to have no impact on
either cleavage or biology
so the libraries themselves are designed
using a series of rules these are based
on the latest findings of specificity
and efficiency of guide RNA binding as
well as the in-house experience that we
have here at Thermo Fisher Scientific so
first we identify the target low SCI
where in Dell formation will result or
where we expected the result and knock
out of all the isoforms of a particular
gene so we look for the most five prime
constitutively expressed exons for any
particular gene we then identify all the
available guide RNAs in those locations
and then we score and filter those
available guide RNAs based on their
expected binding efficiency of the
ribonucleoprotein complex to the target
sequence and we apply a series of rules
that assess sequence complexity GC
content the protis proto spacer adjacent
motif or the pam sequence preference and
the nucleotide positional preference
with those remaining guides we score
those further based on the sequence
specificity so we take that series of
top guides and we bioinformatics at all
of the potential off target sites and we
take the top guides with the least
number of off targets and then filter
out any overlapping sequences and now
have the top four highest scoring guides
that we include in the library build so
I just gave you a description of sort of
how we've organized the libraries how we
have designed the vector backbones and
how we've designed the guides and now
what I'll talk about is how do we use
those libraries to develop an assay and
and generate or execute a screen so the
first is of course to identify and
obtain the CRISPR library that you want
to use what is the content that you
would like to target the second is to
identify the proper cell background for
the
the phenotype or the disease that you're
interested in as well as an assay that
will allow you to interrogate the
biology of interest in that cell
background the next milestone in your in
your journey will be to transduce and
and to optimize the transduction and the
assay itself so not just optimizing how
you get the virus in and optimizing
cleavage but optimizing the readout and
and the time required to get the best
readout possible and then once you've
done that you can move forward with your
CRISPR library screen now I will talk
about all these steps and I just will at
this point also let you know that in
addition to providing these libraries my
teams do provide this workflow as a
service so if for any reason you may
have the desire to outsource it that is
a function that we make available now
this is a the first step again what what
library what content are you interested
in so these are the subsets of the genes
that I mentioned earlier the top 17 they
are shown and they are all available now
with the exception of the transcription
factor set which we expect to roll out
in about one week and then the druggable
genome and the whole genome are going
through production now we expect those
to be wrapped up by the end of q3 and q4
of this year respectively and again you
can see here the number of genes in each
set and the number of guides which again
typically is is four times the number of
genes so on the next slide here I'm
showing you the types of cleavage
efficiency that we can obtain by using
this lentiviral approach on the top
we're comparing two different methods of
generating the caste nine CRISPR RNP
complex so on the very top line we're
simply transducing
these HT 1080 cells with both a cast 9
lentiviral particle and the arrayed guy
RNA lentiviral particles and selecting
with pure myosin for 5 days and then
looking at cleavage at the specific gene
using our genomic cleavage detection sa
kit which I'm sure many of you are
familiar with there the basic idea is
we're looking for formation of hetero
duplexes that occur if we've created in
those that hetero duplex typically
results in a bubble and that that bubble
can be cut by an endonuclease and when
we run those products out on a gel you
can clearly see a difference in the
cleavage which you'll see on the gels on
the lower part of this slide so in the
top left panel for instance we have the
negative control with the dual infection
shown in red and the stable cell I'm
shown in blue so yeah
the stable cell line there we're just
applying the guide RNA lentiviral
particles directly to an HT 1080 that
has been generated to stabili Express
the cast 9 and I'll talk about how we do
that in the next slide so in the dual
and the stable for the negative on the
top left you see single bands indicating
that there was no cleavage at sites
related at negative control however when
we start looking at genes for instance
the PR kcq gene you can see in the dual
infection when we've got the other
components there we get a lower band on
the bottom left and we get about a 90
point 6 cleavage efficiency when we
compare the density of the lower band of
the upper and on the stable we get about
65% when you look through the genes
overall you can see for flit 1 we get
about 73 in the dual about 53 in the
stable 87 and 74 for ER n 256 and 72 for
CLK 188 and 82 for a raf moving over to
the other side on the bottom right cam k
for 83 and 90 so generally these numbers
are in so
of the same ballpark in some cases the
dual infection gave us better better
targeting than the staid one in other
cases the stable you know again I think
that at the end of the day the approach
that you use is going to be very cell
type-specific
it's worth testing both and in some
cases the stable will give you more
robust results and repeatable but in
others that may not be that may not be
an option based on the longevity or the
passage limit of the cell for instance
now the other piece as I mentioned is a
biological endpoint so you choose your
group of targets which have been
organized and QC bias you choose a cell
background and you choose an assay now
we have multiple functional assays in
our molecular probes and in our
discovery portfolios these include a
number of things that allow you to
measure cell health for instance our
live dead assay our presto blue
metabolic a say our Sullivant cast based
assay we have reagents that allow us to
look at mitochondrial lead ox and and
overall cell based redox states we have
a number of pathway based cells our cell
sensor platform that allows you to look
at the activation of an entire pathway
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that today we have our Lampa screen
assays that allow you to interrogate
post translational modification using TR
fret readouts and we have other reporter
genes such as luciferase and beta
galactosidase available from the high
content screening perspective we have
ways of interrogating protein
localization and translocation we can
also do reporter gene expression assays
know right outgrowth migration etc and
we have a number of ways of looking at
second messenger signaling calcium flux
membrane potential ion channels looking
at potassium flux using our flux or
reagent so a wide range of ways to
interrogate the biology
and it's just again a question of what
is the disease and the proper model that
you want to be using so again what I'll
talk to you today about is how we used
the libraries to set up an assay using
one of our cell sensor lines these use a
beta lactamase reporter technology to
provide a very rapid and sensitive
method for looking at signal
transduction pathways shown here is a
picture of the substrate and what you'll
note is that we have a coumarin like
molecule shown on the left that can be
excited by 409 nanometer light and that
is linked to a floor scene or a Fitzie
like molecule shown in green that can
emit one excited at 520 nanometer light
and those are connected through a
beta-lactam ring which is shown in red
now when the beta lactamase enzyme is
expressed it Cleaves that beta-lactam
ring liberating these two fluorophores
and now if you excite the blue
fluorophore with the 409 nanometer light
it will emit 447 because it does not
transfer energy to the green fluorophore
so we have a nice ratiometric way of
measuring this substrate which is also
provides very high signal-to-noise in
these assays makes the assay less
dependent on cell number helps normalize
against bleaching or reflux of the dye
by certain cells that may try to pump it
out as well as against artifacts that
may come from plate readers like light
flash etc now we're going to be using
our NE 180 and F Kappa B cell line so
shown on the left is a pathway in its
most simplistic form in this cell line
in the MU 180 cell which is a cancer
cell line we can activate the TNF alpha
receptor which once activated activate
Strad and the ikk complex this
ultimately results in the
phosphorylation of
i ka beta alpha and release of the NF
kappa-b
complex which can now translocate to the
nucleus buying the NF kappa-b response
element which we have in front of the
beta lactamase enzyme and it can drive
expression of the beta lactamase enzyme
so of course these cells are stable e
expressing cells that we've previously
engineered with the response element
driving the beta lactamase enzyme and
have qualified extensively for small
molecule screening we have about 60 of
these cell lines that represent about 26
different pathways associated with
things such as inflammation cancer
toxicity development stress etc and each
of them has a very thick in most cases
thick validation pack that describes how
the cell line was made how the small
molecule assay was validated and in many
cases how the pathway was validated by
knocking out key components with Si RNA
to validate the biology of the cell and
you can see on the right here in the
absence of TNF alpha the pathway is off
and when we load the cells with the
spread base substrate our live blazer
substrate you can see that as we excite
the cells with blue light they appear
green because of the fret based reaction
of the substrate however on the bottom
right when we add TNF alpha the enzyme
is expressed it Cleaves that beta-lactam
ring and again now when we excite with
blue light excite the blue fluorophore
we see emission of the blue floor for in
the cells appear blue so the next step
for
was to take that cell line and generate
a safe stable caste 9 expressing cell
line using our Lenti array Castine virus
so we simply transduced we added
Blastoise Eden of course we ran an
antibiotic kill curve to determine the
appropriate concentration of Blastoise
Eden to use and we added it selected for
about 14 to 21 days we clonally isolated
the cells and expanded those and then
characterized and validated individual
clones by both Western blot shown on the
bottom left so you see a number of
clones they're depicted with a
alphanumeric number and beta-actin
standing that goes along with that to
normalize and then on the right you'll
see some of those same clones tested in
a cleavage analysis essay at the hprt
locus so here we choose the clones that
had the lowest level of caste 9
expression but gave the highest level of
cleavage and showed the same morphology
as the parent and the same growth rates
as the parent okay and you will note
that the cleavage analysis does vary a
little bit more significantly than one
might expect based on simply the
expression level so we do absolutely
suggest that if you're going to go
through the trouble of clonally
isolating cells that you do base your
decision on which clone to use on the
cleavage analysis and again the
morphology and the growth rate of those
cells so next we wanted to optimize the
assay so we took that caste 9 stable
cell line and on the top two panels
you'll see that we plated cells out at
two different cell densities in a 384
well plate and we tested four different
mo eyes one through four and we examined
hprt
trad and beta lactamase itself now hprt
we expect to have no impact on the NF
kappa-b pathway
trad as i showed you as an early player
in that pathway if we knock it out we
should have a significant impact on the
pathway and beta lactamase of course
being the reporter enzyme itself if we
knock it out we should essentially
eliminate the signal so we're looking
for an mo eye condition
that gives us essentially no effect at
the hprt and the greatest effect of the
PR ad D&B la targets and what we decided
here was looking at the blue bars of an
mo eye of two we really get good and
significant knockdown of trad and BL a
and they're relatively equivalent at
either one thousand or two thousand
cells per well we also looked at whether
or not we needed to use spin oculus
enduring our transduction protocol and
how far out we needed to read the assay
of course when you knock out the gene
after that's been done you need to wait
for the transcript to decay and you need
to wait for the protein to decay so
there is some timing aspect and again we
want to make sure that we've optimized
the assay window to be as big as
possible in the shortest amount of time
so what we see here is that we really
saw no difference in the use of spin
ocular that's the red versus the blue
bars and the middle panels and from day
five to day eight we really saw no
significant difference either so this
could be read out as early as day five
and spin oculi ssin was optional or
unnecessary we also tested whether or
not we needed Purim Ison selection on
the cells and we looked at that at day 5
and day 9 and what you'll see then in
those bottom panels is again comparing
the red to the blue bars very little
difference as to whether or not we
include a pure myosin and very little
difference between day 5 and day 9 you
know a little bit of a smaller a little
bit more inhibition at trad but not
terribly significant so we felt that it
was best for us
Anasazi to go ahead and read out at day
5 and to omit the pure myosin selection
because we are getting very high levels
of transduction using the methods that
we had optimized so how does it look
here's an example then of taking that
caste 9 expressing so sensor NF kappa-b
emmy 180 line adding our guide RNA
particles and then four days post
transduction adding tnf-alpha and making
our measurement so on the bottom panel
again on the left you see in the
absence of tnf-alpha all the cells are
green because there is no beta lactamase
the pathway is not on when we add
tnf-alpha in the presence of the
scrambled control or the hprt control
most of the cells are blue because we
have turned the pathway on and we can
now see engagement of the reporter
however when we knock out beta lactamase
on the top right or the TNF alpha
receptor on the bottom left or ikk alpha
in the bottom middle or T rat on the
bottom right most of the cells are green
because we have now disrupted the
pathway and the beta lactamase enzyme is
either not made or knocked out and the
substrate remains intact so this looked
great and here's a little blow-up of the
TNF alpha receptor knockout I just want
you to appreciate how penetrant this is
nearly a hundred percent of the cells
shown in this field are green indicating
that they were knocked out so we wanted
to do a little bit of a verification on
that assay we followed up on a few of
the specific hits here or the specific
controls we asked when looking at T rat
or ikk alpha for instance we did genomic
analysis of the target sites by next-gen
sequencing using our ion torrent PGM and
and/or proton platforms and what you'll
see for T rat is that we're getting
somewhere on the order of 98% in delft
formation and for ikk alpha somewhere on
the order of 83 84 % so that looked
pretty good we next looked at the
proteins themselves and you can see
below the cells were expanded for 14
days and we ran western blots in the
case of no guide RNA on the bottom left
panel you can see a very clear band for
the ikk alpha whereas in the knockout
cells there's essentially no band there
likewise on the right for T rad when we
look in the no guide RNA treated cells
we can see it
and whereas when we look at the trap
knock out there's essentially no band
visible on top again we quantitated that
functionally using the live blazer
substrate and with the tear ad and the
ikk alpha you can see the large bulb of
the cells are green again indicating a
knock out of that pathway and when we
quantitate that by measuring the
Bluegreen ratio using the substrate and
comparing it to the control situations
we get about a 90% knockout or 90
percent inhibition of the pathway by the
trad knock out and around 83% by the ikk
alpha so again this looks very good to
us we are getting a very high rate of in
delft formation a very clear and high
rate of protein knockout and a very
clear and correlative functional
knockout that could be quantitated using
our live blazer si you did one final
secondary verification using immuno site
of chemical techniques and what you can
see on the far left and the panel of 6a
through H on top we have a some some
microscopic immuno fluorescent
micrographs in the absence of tnf-alpha
thats panels a through D and on the
bottom in the presence of tnf-alpha so
in the absence of guide RNA you can see
in blue the nucleus and in green you can
see the NF kappab alpha the NF kappa-b
gfp fusion protein and the translocation
of that protein is evident in panel e
compared to panel a when we add TNF
alpha however when we add when we look
at the trap knockout or the ikk alpha
knockout in panels C and D in the
absence of TNF alpha you see the
cytosolic distribution of NF kappa-b
and in the presence of tnf-alpha in
panels G and H you see a persistent
cytosolic localization of NF kappa-b
instead of the nuclear localization that
you see in panel e so this is just an
orthogonal assay that allowed us to
functionally validate what we are seeing
in the cell sensor acid and on the right
we also looked at ikk alpha using an
antibody against ikk alpha and you can
see in the no guide RNA in the presence
and absence of TNF alpha we have this is
a phospho specific antibody we have
activation of ikk alpha that you can see
in panel C but in panel D that's absent
because we've knocked out ikk alpha
entirely okay so we felt really good
about the acid development our controls
were behaving the way we expect our
cleavage or protein back out or
functional assays are behaving the way
we expect we now embark I'm setting up
the assay so as mentioned we used our
optimized si variables in a 384 well
plate 1000 cells per well mo I of 2 we
tested three wells for each target on
stem and stem and we used a number of
controls on each plate no cells no
lentivirus which is a negative control
of course hprt GFP which was a negative
control anak transduction control
lactamase which was a positive control
that we consider a technical control and
then a number of genes that we know to
be related to the pathway C phos ikk
alpha and TNF alpha receptor which are
all biological controls and again I
think this is very important when you
run these screens that you maintain a
series of controls on each plate so that
you can understand that your assay is
working as intended on each plate and
you can interpret your data
appropriately for our screen we use the
Len tree Lenti array CRISPR human kinase
library which has about 840 targets
and on the right you see the acetate
protocol we seeded the cells in 5%
growth medium 30 micro liters per well
spun the plate for 2 minutes at room
temp added the lentivirus in 5% growth
media at an mo I have to with poly brain
at 10 microliters per well spun those
plates for 30 minutes at room
temperature incubated and on day 5 added
medium with 5x stimulation buffer
incubated again for about 5 hours
load with the BL a substrate and read
the B la si this slide shows you a plate
map of all the targets and controls that
I just mentioned so again we have three
wells per target and in white that's in
the absence of TNF alpha and grey in the
presence and then on the right we have a
series of the controls that I mentioned
so blanks no lentivirus hprt
a number of biological controls and beta
lactamase so how does it look on the
left I'm showing you the inter plate
reproducibility of the controls so that
library of 840 kinases translates to
about 16 384 well plates the way that we
configured the assay so we have about 16
dots here representing the controls and
you can see that these are clustered
quite nicely so our are no Lenti a very
little variation a little more from HP
RT and C Foss and very tight grouping
for trad TNF R and beta lactamase on the
right what you'll see our black dots for
each one of the targets and then we've
highlighted a few targets Chuck plk for
neck 4 and pkn 1 that are known to be
involved in some fashion and the NF
kappa-b pathway and then those those
colored bars represent the controls that
i've shown you on the left and there
standard deviations so here we drew a
red line and in this case this is a
little bit arbitrary this is based on
essentially a where the hprt
control is we don't really expect hprt
to be having an impact although we do
see that there there is something going
on there that may be in part due to the
virus it may be in part due to some
ancillary impact of the hprt enzyme and
other enzymes in this pathway that is
unknown to us but we felt that anything
above that we can consider a negative
and anything below that we can consider
a positive we also want to like any
screen sort of pick a number that is
relevant to the capacity that we have to
follow up so we draw that red line there
and capture all the hits below that and
that is shown here on our hit follow up
on the left top left panel we Bend all
the hits and you can see that this
histogram is a little bit asymmetric on
the left we obviously don't have a very
clear peak but those of you that are
accustomed to looking at small molecules
screening you'll always have that a bit
of a trail on your hits and again we
made it somewhat arbitrary line and
captured 75 hits to follow up on well
you see on the bottom left panel then
are some compounds that we tested that
are annotated to have activity at
specific kinases so plk for at PK n at
ikk for instance and those are called
out over here on the right where NF
Kappa B pathway diagram from The Keg
analysis and website is highlighted with
some of those known hits circled in red
that are also represented than by the
annotated compound so again we do have
we do have
some known hits we follow up with some
known compounds in this assay we also
have a number of unknowns those are
things that we are following up on now
using both si RNA technology taking the
guides and following up with the single
guides for each gene instead of the four
guide pool and testing other annotated
compounds against some of these putative
lis unknown kinases in this pathway so
hopefully sometime in the next year
we'll be able to come back to you with
some additional information about how we
followed up on these hits and what we
learned about the unknowns now very
briefly I want to tell you a little bit
about work that has been done by one of
our collaborators at Northwestern
University dr. Simone's red knee
she has a long-standing interest in rare
pediatric brain cancer and as we were
building out the library she kindly
offered to assist us in testing some of
our prototypes and she using parts of
our kinase library developed an assay in
a Mon cell line that she uses with
collaborators from the past your
Institute that represents one of these
eight er tier a boy tumors a very
malignant very aggressive pediatric
brain tumor it's a rare disease only
around 60 people per year may be
diagnosed with this disease but the
prognosis is absolutely horrible there
is no treatment if the children are
treated they may have a very short
extension to their life but you know
this is a diagnosis that a doctor does
not want to give to a parent so Simone
and her team took these viruses they
made a cast 9 Mon cell and then they
introduced the guides into the viruses
and created stable pools of cells and
actually measured shown here in the
middle panel on the top labeled B to
actually measure the time that it took
the cells to reach
influence and you'll see here comparing
a set of tiny is's on the right some of
these are not listed because Simone has
identified some very interesting targets
that she plans to follow up on but plk
four is one that she's published already
on and I encourage you to check out this
article it is available open access and
you see the plk four had a significant
slowing to reach confluence compared to
the negative control scramble and the
positive control HP RT which should have
no impact on these cells shown on the
bottom left bars with her we followed up
by doing some NGS here at our site in
Carlsbad and this is looking at the PL
k4 in Dells and all these black lines
essentially are showing you in Dells at
that area and we got very high levels of
cleavage of PL k4 with I think three out
of four of the guides but one of them
actually which is shown on the top panel
which was in a slightly different low
side we didn't get very good cleavage
nevertheless that was enough for us to
be able to to run for her to run these
assays on the bottom left she's looking
at these maan nine Cass nine cells and
then the ma nine cast 9p okay for cells
and asking how do they change in
proliferation based on anti ki-67
staining and you can see a significant
difference between the cast nine
parental and the cast nine that
expresses the guide in the middle panel
she's showing a Kelowna genic assay
where they see a small number of cells
and ask what is the capacity of these
cells to generate colony forming units
and you can see a very significant
difference again between the cast nine
expressing line and the cast nine line
that has the guide on the bottom right
this led them to ask then well how
important is PL k4 in these cells
because it had not been really caught by
differential gene expression studies but
now when they look more carefully at
normal brain tissue shown on the far
right and non-embryonic brain tuner
tumors versus the embryo no or a TRT
brain tumors which are the data sets
shown on the two
left scatterplots they could see a
significant difference between these a
trt and these embryonal brain tumors
versus again non-embryonic or normal
brain tissue so that was a piece that
had not been appreciated before because
it was a very small difference it wasn't
coming up out of the differential gene
expression profiles but here based on
the knockout data that she had she was
able to actually discover this
difference in gene expression which is
in fact significant she then went on to
look at a compound that a group in
Toronto that she knew had been working
on for a different oncology indication
and I believe this compound is being
tested for breast cancer and it's a
specific P okay for inhibitor and she
asked will this small molecule have the
same impact as my knockout and in this
top panel she tested that small molecule
against the mom cells as well as a
series of other ATR t type cancers G 401
B T - 12 and BT 16 and these bars
represent concentration response curves
at 48 and 72 hours and again especially
at the 72 hour time point you can see
that with increasing concentration of
the compounds against these cells in an
MT T proliferation assay you can see a
significant decrease in cellular
proliferation of these cancer cells she
also ran chlorogenic acids of this
compound against these cell lines using
50 nano molar of the compound and again
could show a very significant impact and
the ability of these cells to form
clone clone agenda form colony forming
units in the Kelowna genic acid so very
we were very excited by Simone's work
here this is a very preliminary piece
and she was able to very quickly extract
value from these knockout studies and we
just couldn't be happier that again as
Julie mentioned our mission is to enable
our customers to make the world
to your place and you know this really
aligns with that and we wish Simone
continued success and will continue to
collaborate with her in fact by now
building a higher throughput assay that
will allow us to work with her to test
the rest of the chi know and perhaps the
entire genome in some of these models to
identify the best targets that may help
the children that are suffering from
these diseases so finally I would just
like to wrap up and summarize what I
hope I have communicated to you today we
believe our Lenti array CRISPR libraries
are a powerful high-throughput
loss-of-function screening tool that can
be used to support target identification
these libraries are built as flexible
systems that can be adapted to beat the
needs of your screening goals and your
model systems we have 19 predefined
libraries that give you the ability to
construct custom gene sets and the
flexibility to perform everything from a
completely unbiased whole genome Survey
to highly focused screens and again I
want to take that back to the very
beginning of the talk although I have
focused a little bit more on a pathway
and a disease remember that as you get
hits that come out of phenotypic screens
this may be a way for you to
deconvolution the Lenti array libraries
contain up to for high quality guide RNA
constructs per gene per well and provide
a library that is very effective in a
wide variety of cell types and I'm sure
that we and our other collaborators will
continue to share more in the next year
as some of this data comes out the Lenti
array library portfolio provides all the
tools that you need to apply the power
of the CRISPR cast 9 technology to your
screening efforts and again we have a
great number of tools in our box around
assay development as well and as
mentioned these tools can be put to use
on your behalf in our service offerings
as well so finally with that I just like
to say
and thank you for your attendance and
participation today
it looks like we've got a number of
questions that have lined up and we will
take those and I will just again say
thank you all for your attendance
thank you dr. Piper for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar also we would
appreciate your participation in a brief
questionnaire which you will see on your
screen if you have a question you'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window cut your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question we will follow up with you via
email after the presentation so let's
get started the first question is I was
confused by the dual inception versus
stable expression of Cavs 9 can you talk
a little bit more about that when why
would you use stable expression versus
dual infection of Cavs 9 I think thanks
for the question
so the in some cases cells are
immortalized cells and can essentially
be passaged
in perpetuity in those cases it's it's
typically relatively simple to apply to
cast 9 virus allow it to stay blue
integrate and select with Blastoise eden
and either use that stable pool or
generate a clonal population and use
that clonal population for the assay now
generally speaking I think most people
in the screening world feel a little
more comfortable with that stable line
because you feel like it's not going to
drift it's going to maintain the same
properties from passage to passage and
assay to assay it's something that you
could easily share with other colleagues
or collaborators in your organization on
the other hand
there are certain cell types including
primary cells that may be dividing but
have limited passage have passage limits
maybe they can only be passage 20 times
before they start to differentiate or
change sort of their biology based on
being in vitro for that long so in most
cases it may be challenging to insert
the caste 9 and go through the passages
required to get the selected pool or
clone and in those cases you really need
to do the dual transduction and that's
really essentially based on the cell
type now again for cells that can be
passaged sort of in perpetuity you could
do either one so it you know if time is
of the essence you might want to just
use the dual transduction because you
want to get the data you know generating
the cell line obviously is going to take
somewhere between one and three months
depending on whether you make a stable
pool or a clone so it's a little bit of
a balance between the biology that the
cell offers you and the time that you
have to get your experiments done thank
you the next question is can you talk a
little bit more about when one would
want to use a pooled vs. array CRISPR
library sure so in the pooled approaches
in most cases what people have done is
you you apply a pool that contains all
of the guides for all of the genes so
let's say you have 20,000 genes times 10
guides that's 200,000 guides now you
need to apply that pool to your cells at
a high level of coverage at least say a
hundredfold
maybe a thousandfold so you need at
least 200,000 times 100 what is that 20
million or 200 million cells minimum to
get your assay done because when you
apply the the guide something is going
to change in the population so when you
knock out a gene either cells are going
to die for instance if you've got some
cancer cells and you're looking for a
gene knockout that kills them they're
going to either slow their proliferation
or
I or it's possible that you actually
when you not got a gene that the cells
could be enriched they might survive
certain conditions better than the other
cells after that application you're
going to next-gen sequence your pool of
cells and you're going to look at the
guides and you're going to ask which
ones are misrepresented which have been
depleted compared to your controls or
which have been enriched compared to
your controls so that approach works
well as long as your assay or the cell
type or the biology is going to allow
you to be looking at the enrichment or
depletion of cells also you will need
some bioinformatic analysis of those
sequencing results which is not
necessarily the most straightforward
thing it can certainly be done but not
all labs have those tools today now if
you want to look at something more
functional like neurite outgrowth or
mitochondrial health or phosphorylation
of a protein that's another that's going
to be very challenging to dual do in a
pooled approach if you do that in a in
an irate approach you can make that
measurement in the well with that target
and you will know immediately what the
impact of that target was and for that
matter even in a proliferation assay
while it can be done in the pool
approach by doing it with the rate
approach you don't need to deconvolution
has an impact so again it comes down a
little bit to logistics time and to the
tools that you have at hand thank you
next question is what are some of the
common challenges issues that you run
into when running a CRISPR library
screen so I think you know this this
comes that really sort of to the same
sorts of challenges that you face when
you run any kind of high content or high
throughput screen you know it's in part
manipulating the cells themselves and
making sure that you can get the proper
number of cells in the well and keep
them
in that same state for a certain period
of time and get substrate or antibodies
on and off in order to make your
measurements now to that you add the
complication of having to get the
lentivirus on to get high levels of
transduction and if you need antibiotic
selection then maintaining a relatively
normalized cell number through that
antibiotic selection so you know again I
think this really just comes back to
working out the assay development in a
stepwise fashion and I think for each
assay and each cell those problems will
be a little bit different but again it
really comes down to getting good and
efficient transduction getting the
proper number of cells and keeping the
proper number of cells over the duration
of the assay and optimizing around your
window thank you so much we'll wrap up
with one last question and that question
is in your opinion what do you think is
going to be the next big advancement in
CRISPR technology what do you think is
right around the corner wow that's a
that's a big question you know certainly
from the standpoint of the nucleus
itself they're of course different
isoforms and I'm sure that people will
continue to evolve the existing isoforms
so that we will get better cleavage
efficiency and less off target effects I
think that design of the guides and our
ability to accurately predict their
efficiency and their lack of off target
effect will increase you know if our
delivery methods perhaps improvements in
Lenti virus or other viral transduction
the ability to use synthetic guides or
in-vitro guides in RNP complexes in
certain cell types better bioinformatic
tools to analyze the data I think those
are all things so that I'd expect to see
in the next year or two
okay it looks like we had one more
question come in and so what we'll go
ahead and ask that will you eventually
generate the library targeting RNA
binding proteins so once we have the
entire genome constructed and I think
our genome is somewhere between eighteen
and twenty thousand genes you will be
able to access the content of that and
configure any custom set of genes that
you would like so if you can provide a
list of the RNA binding proteins that
you're interested in you will be able to
go directly to our website and request
those genes to be configured and I
believe even configure them in whatever
order you would choose to and you can do
that as pools or single guides so we
have a great deal of flexibility
actually in the way that gene sets can
be made we're doing some custom requests
right now but we are trying to finish
the production of the entire set in
order to make the custom generation
easier in the future I would like to
once again thank dr. Piper for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots and thermo Fisher Scientific
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 25th 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye